you've started
an amazing podcast that we mentioned a
few times uh people should definitely
check it out
it's called the hubermann lab podcast it
uh it does your it's basically
it embodies the personality of andrew
huberman
which is like makes science accessible
um but also uh
fascinating and giving it
like what do you call it you give tools
for everyday life
meaning it kind of grounds in like
what the hell does this mean for my life
but then also does the beauty of science
at the same time so i love i love both
the
the rigor and the openness of the whole
thing plus the whole corrections things
that we mentioned
anyway what's uh been the hardest part
of this whole process
you're one of already one of
the only and one of the best
science podcasters out there so in that
process
what's been the hardest what's been the
most exciting part
wow well first of all thanks for the
kind words about the podcast it was
inspired by you
i i absolutely it's um
that's no bs i the last time we met to
do an interview for your podcast we
talked a little bit about it and
you gave me the um subtle nudge that
maybe there was a
there was a podcast there and i thought
about it and i left and i was just like
i gotta do this thing and
you really gave me the encouragement to
do it now your podcast this podcast has
really forged the way
you've been tip of the spear on serious
scientific intellectual yet fun
accessible conversation and so
i as your colleague and
friend and but i just even if those
things weren't true like
this this podcast was and is the
inspiration there's no question so much
yeah i really like 100 percent and
when i decided to do the podcast the
hebrew lab podcast
i thought really long and hard about
what would work best and would be most
beneficial
turned out to be the hardest thing which
is to stay on a single topic
for three or four or more episodes
before switching to a new topic
because i know from the experience of
university and teaching in university as
you know
as well that there's always the
temptation to pivot to something else
but the drilling into something really
deeply is where the where the gems
reside and the the challenge has been
how to make it interesting how to keep
people on board how to give people tools
along the way
but also stay close to the scientific
data um
i like to think that we're headed in the
right direction it still needs to evolve
but that's been a challenge
i think i also am challenged by the fact
that there's a tremendous range of
backgrounds of listeners
so some people have asked for more names
like
more bits and parts of the nervous
system and cellular molecular mechanisms
and all that kind of thing
and other people said i don't understand
any of that stuff but i think i'm
keeping up and so
unlike a university course where there
are prerequisites and everyone's coming
to the table with more or less the same
knowledge i have a very limited sense of
what the audience knows and doesn't know
so that's why i incorporated the feature
of the comment section on youtube
being a source of feedback and i
do a kind of an office hours like
episode
every third or fourth episode where i
address common questions
and i think that the podcast space in my
mind
um at least for the sort of podcast i'm
doing
needed a venue for the listeners to be a
more integral part of the experience as
opposed to just commenting on what they
liked or didn't like
so while i like to hear what people
liked and didn't like i also really like
to hear about
hey tell me more about temperature
minimums and how they can be used to
phase shift circadian rhythms or
whatever it is and i realize that i'm
probably losing some people along the
way but hopefully
at the end of each month and because of
the way that the
episodes are archived people will come
away feeling
as if they've learned a ton and they
have tools that they can implement
and perhaps most importantly that
they're starting to think scientifically
about the tons of other stuff that's out
there
so that's been the challenge and it's
still really early days
but um and and of course there's also an
intentional challenge i realize that
people are busy
not everyone has two hours to listen to
a podcast about jet lag and shift work
and raising kids and sleep and that kind
of thing i'm not raising kids but i did
a whole thing about babies and sleep
with
you know and how parents can manage
their sleep when kids aren't sleeping
so it's been um i'm hacking through the
jungle of
all this stuff but and i'll come right
back to i
it my inspiration and my my my
uh north star on this is
getting to a point where the audience
that listens to this feels the same way
that i do when i listen to your podcast
thank you so much like when i tune into
your podcast i'm going to embarrass you
a little bit more by complimenting you a
little bit more
um but not out of a sadistic
thing but just because when i tune into
your podcast or joe's podcast
i have the same sensation that other
people have like i feel like
i'm home of sorts i'm like i'm familiar
with the space
and i'd like people to feel comfortable
in the space that is the hubert lab
podcast whatever that ends up being
yeah that's the magic of podcasting it's
like i feel like i'm part of your life
now in a way
that as a fan that i wouldn't be
otherwise
and you know like i never was able to
have that with carl sagan for example
you know and that's a whole other level
of connection with a human being that
gets you excited
and then i share your excitement about
uh
different topics in neuroscience or just
biology in general and then i don't have
to actually understand everything you're
saying
to uh to really enjoy it so
that that's the magic of podcasting is
like you can go through like 10 minutes
not understanding what the hell a person
is saying
and then you uh enjoy the excitement
and then you reconnect to a thing that
you do understand what they're saying
and you know that's uh that personal
coupled with the scientific rigor is
magic and finding the right
it's exploration like joe found
something that works for comedians which
is like
you know having a good laugh but also
every once in a while
talking seriously about difficult topics
the scientific space it was unclear i
you haven't had guests on not yet but uh
maybe you'll come on as a that's right
i'm just gonna invite my i was gonna try
to follow myself
i am i'm officially inviting you now
will you come on the podcast i would
love to it
was fantastic but it was it was hard
it's still a little bit difficult to
tell people
that no you don't get it we're not going
to talk for 10 minutes
we're gonna talk for three or four hours
it's a different for scientists for like
they're like what i
don't what are we gonna talk about they
think it's like the npr interview
yes and they don't realize first of all
i think at his best if you're like at
the level of joe rogan
who i think is an excellent
conversationalist
it you just lose track of time it can be
three four five
hours and you lose track of time i'm
still not there
i find that it's still painful like the
conversation is still challenging
sometimes
you don't lose quite as much of track of
time it's still an
intellectual effort and i think it might
always be as it would be with you
because you're talking about difficult
topics
maybe that require more brain you're not
just
shooting the with like a brian red
band or somebody like comedians or just
joking
what's like uh remember those shows um
like where
those shows where someone would come out
and like spin plates and they're running
back and forth but
really good scientific discussion is
like that
you have to be maintaining three or four
different logical arguments and jumping
back and forth
it's occasionally getting to like a real
streak of linearity
but as we found today that typically
there's three or four different things
that we're bouncing back and forth
and that requires a lot of updating of
these you know forebrain circuits it's
not
it's not a passive listening experience
but i like to think that the brain likes
that
i i do want to ask just because we all
i don't want to forget the the question
came up to me
is your podcast has
the same kind of rigor that i think like
a dan carlin podcast has
a history podcaster well that's a
definitely a compliment thank you it's a
handstand way
you know he's something for me to aspire
to so he goes through
hell to prepare he spends months
preparing it feels like
you've had to really prepare for your
podcast i definitely
prepare hard how does that are you okay
yeah i mean how much effort does that
take
it feels like a conference presentation
yeah so we record once a week
and in the intervening time i listen
to many
university level lectures so nih has a
bank of lectures i have some sources of
recorded university seminars
i'm trying to find the the points of
intersection so like for four episodes
on sleep it's not like i'm gonna
just regurgitate a popular book or take
one lecture and just
you know poach the content i'm gonna
find the overlap
in the different elements i also so what
i'll do is
i'll generally read 10 or 15
papers and generally those are good
reviews annual reviews
interview of neuroscience annual review
of physiology those kinds of things
i'll chase a few references i'll listen
to some youtube videos but of university
level lectures
and then i throw all that on a
whiteboard usually while i work out in
the morning
i'll just be working out i have a gym in
my house and i'll i just put up
all these random ideas i want to cover
that dreams hallucination
and then i take that and i start
eliminating i draw lines between the
common points of intersection
and then from that i i distill out an
outline
and then i basically think about what i
want to say
on my walks with my dog and i bother a
couple people and blabbed to them so i
would say each podcast
yeah i put in 10 to 15 hours at least of
passive listening preparation and maybe
five or six of active preparation
so i do prepare quite a lot but it has a
certain reward component for me
i to come up at the end with something
that's somewhat crystallized
for me is just so satisfying it feels
like there's something about my dopamine
circuits that just love that
and uh the the only pain is that a year
later after i've talked about the stuff
a bunch of times
it's so much more succinct but that's
life you you know at some
point you got to pull the trigger well
the i don't know what you think
but for me youtube is uh that's why i'm
sad that joe left youtube
there's a archival nature to youtube
that's kind of magical so i'm really
glad you're now
you're you you're uh
doing a lot of educational content on
instagram before
but now on doing this podcast thing on
youtube
it's like a you know it's like feynman
lectures like well that's very no
i'm not saying every podcast right but
there will be there
you will have some i could already tell
there will be some
lectures which are like
definitive like really special ones
that's the hope and the there's some
aspect that's archival to youtube where
at least i hope like 20 years from now
some kid is going to watch
uh watch a lecture yours and
[Music]
you know it'll it'll create the next
nobel prize right it'll create
it'll create another uh you know a dream
that then becomes a reality and that
that's a that's a special thing
that um that youtube provides i'm really
excited that you're on youtube
and at the same time i'm excited to see
where this thing goes
because um it seems like change is the
uh the cliched thing the change is the
only constant in these times
because you're paving uh
with this podcast with this creativity
what you were doing on instagram as well
you're paving the new era
of what it means to do science so
actively doing research
and actively explaining that research
and new media
it's it's very interesting just fired
and
genuinely inspired by you we we had this
discussion last time
after the podcast recording and it was
it's clear that communication of science
cannot be left
to the the existing institutions and i'm
talking about universities i just mean
that the
science section of newspapers is
sometimes there's some gems there but
generally it goes you know and yeah i
think you really have to know a field
in order to extract the best things from
that field and my hope is that other
practicing scientists and people
finishing their phd in postdoc and
people who are running labs or working
at companies will start to do this i
mean how amazing would it be for
instance
if if someone at neural link
was giving us hints about not
necessarily what they're developing
because that's
complicated for all sorts of reasons but
would
talk to us about what the real
challenges
of building futuristic brain machine
interface are like and
and what the what it means to understand
a clinical problem and address it i mean
i
my hope is somebody there might
eventually do that that somebody in the
world of
um chemistry or synthetic materials or
whatever it is will do this in a way
that i could understand because i don't
have
expertise in those i think it would be
marvelous
and um your tip of the spear you were
out first and um
i'm just uh happily trying to
to move along in the direction i'm going
but i i think the future of science
education is online
and and i think that's going to be scary
to a lot of
existing institutions but it's not about
disrupting anything it's just about
trying to do things better yeah
you